das ist absolut irre es gibt ja schon
lange die vermutung dass das leben aus
dem all auf die erde kam und dieser
wirklich super spannende fund ist ein
sehr deutlicher hinweis in diese
richtung einem japanischen
forschungsteam gelangen diese entdeckung
als sie einen meteoriten analysierten
der 1969 in australien eingeschlagen war
sie spürten ein lebenswichtiges
biomolekül auf das offensichtlich aus
dem weltall auf die erde gelangt kann es
also sein dass teile unseres erbgutes
außerirdischen ursprungs sind fix und
science fiction gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst er nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen schon in den 60er jahren
hatten forschungsteams hinweise darauf
gefunden dass biologischer zucker wie
glukose in kohlenstoffhaltigen
urtümlichen meteoriten vorkommen doch es
gelang den fachleuten damals nicht eine
extraterrestrische herkunft zu beweisen
anfang der 2000er jahre nahmen
forschende den sogenannten merchants in
meteoriten ins visier der 169 in
australien eingeschlagen war und
tatsächlich auch hier konnten zucker
alkohol und zucker säure nachgewiesen
werden doch diese damals nachgewiesene
verbindung aus dem all
neben kein besonderes schlüsselrolle in
organismen ein der fall jetzt ist
komplett anders und das macht ihn so
mind blowing ein japanisches
forschungsteam hat sich den merchants in
meteoriten und weitere urtümliche
kohlenstoffhaltige methoden noch einmal
genauer vorgenommen bei den gesteins
untersuchungen spürten die fachleute
insgesamt vier arten von zucker auf ihr
grundgerüst besteht aus jeweils fünf
kohlenstoffatom konkret konnten die
forschenden rose arabinose psychose und
glückshose nachweisen und das ist
wirklich der hammer
denn zucker ist für alle lebensformen
enorm wichtig und ermöglicht
verschiedene biologische prozesse klose
beispielsweise bildet nichts geringeres
als das grundgerüst unseres erbgutes
gemeint sind die app moleküle arena und
die dna für die idee so psychose eine
entscheidende rolle spielt auf der rna
und dna sind alle informationen
gespeichert die für einen organismus
lebensnotwendig sind die weitere analyse
des japanischen forschungsteams legt
dass diese zuckermoleküle tatsächlich
aus dem alt stammen
hinweise darauf liefert das verhältnis
der verschiedenen kohlenstoff varianten
hin zucker die fachleute kamen nämlich
zu dem ergebnis dass das so genannte
kohlenstoff 13 isotop
überdurchschnittlich oft vorkommt andere
bodenproben rund um die einsatzstelle
des merchants in meteoriten in
australien wiesen dagegen einen sehr
geringen anteil von kohlenstoff 13 auf
diese ergebnisse sprechen gegen eine
verunreinigung des meteoriten auf der
erde sondern legen eine außerirdische
herkunft nahe dass japanische
forschungsteam vermutet dass diese
lebenswichtigen biomoleküle also eins im
all entstanden sind und dann mit
meteoriten auf die erde gelandet
ihre entstehung müsste also unter nicht
biologischen bedingungen im weltraum
geschehen sein die forschenden nahmen
sich diesen rätsel an und simulierten
dafür im labor einen möglichen prozess
dieser ähnelt der sogenannten famose bei
der zucker aus all den hüten entsteht
dabei handelt es sich um dekorierte
alkohole gab es dann vielleicht einst
sogar eine art zucker regen der auf die
erde und andere planeten wie
beispielsweise den mars niedergegangen
ist das japanische forschungsteam
vermutet dass sich dadurch andere
wichtige biomoleküle bilden konnten
beispielsweise rna dna und atp das für
die energiegewinnung der zellen eine
entscheidende schlüsselrolle spielt das
würde die perspektive auf die entstehung
von leben komplett verändern dann wäre
das nämlich ein prozess der im
kompletten weltalls stattfindet damit
würden gar nicht mehr so ganz spezielle
bedingungen auf planeten nötig sein und
leben wäre dann der normalfall keine
ausnahme das weltall wäre voll damit und
wir könnten es viel leichter finden
wahnsinn es gibt kaum ein thema das
spannender ist deshalb ihr also hier
alles und alles wirklich alles über
aliens gibt es sie gibt sie nicht wie
sehen sie aus wann finden wir sie und so
weiter und so fort unsere große druck wo
also die doku des wissenschafts
netzwerkes essent 1054 mit ganz vielen
teilnehmenden kanälen in form einer
playlist also anklicken anschauen und am
besten alle kanäle abonnieren supercool
und kommentiert hier drunter
ob er sie komplett gesehen habt und was
ihr denkt bis dann bleibt dran